self-confidence without that skill we
are useless because when you lose sight
or belief in yourself we're done for
I use the definition of self-confidence
to be the ability or the belief to
believe in yourself to accomplish any
task no matter the odds no matter the
difficulty no matter the adversity the
problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the tasks we're doing is
not novel is not new to us we want to be
in a situation where we've created we've
had so much pressure in that and what I
mean because pressure builds diamonds we
want to be in a situation where hey I've
done this a thousand times because I
make enough mistakes and the newspapers
will recognize it and people around me
will recognize it and they'll tear me
down and pretty soon I'll begin to
believe it there was a time when my
confidence was really low
because there are moments and we'll all
experience them in our career
in our life and our job hunting and our
relationships when we are not feeling
good about who and what and where we are
how good should you feel about yourself
well you know you might say well you
should Grant yourself the right to exist
like you do everyone else you know
that's sort of like a basic human right
as a human being you're valuable and
then maybe you should sort of think
you're about as valuable as other people
roughly think you are that seems about
right right so the right amount of
self-esteem would be
your perception of your value within the
context of a group how much misery about
yourself do you have to have before
you're motivated to improve yourself
none
well that doesn't seem right but we also
don't know whether it's shame or guilt
or anxiety or pain or you know these
negative emotions that motivate you now
it's clear that if you have enough
negative emotion not to paralyze you
everyone has the same two deepest fears
All Humans I don't care I've dealt with
greatest athletes in the world
multi-billionaires you know guys in
prison you name the kids we all are
afraid we're not enough at some point if
you feel like you're not young enough
strong enough old enough but sure enough
funny enough Rich enough something
enough for someone who you really want
to be enough for it brings up an even
deeper fear which is if I'm not enough I
won't be loved and love is the oxygen of
the soul and you don't get over it
you've got Beyond it and the way you get
Beyond it is you just train yourself I
don't say in a minute when I'm ready or
maybe tomorrow it's like I say go we go
so it's a mental training as well as
it's a physical training right and when
you do that over and over and then you
say I'm going to do this your brain
doesn't negotiate you've trained your
own mind a lot of people these
discussions in their own head back and
forth and that's just a habit I think of
three things I'm grateful for about a
minute each and I live them I don't
remember it over there I get in the
roller coaster as it's going down and
feel it and I get Associated to what I'm
most grateful for because gratitude
destroys the two emotions that mess up
your life which are fear and anger and
then what that does is it creates a
foundation that when Winter's here you
go give me winter bastard I'll rip
through that I don't care what it is you
want to do I'm ready but most people you
know they're living their life in front
of a screen a lot of people today
they're living at home right their
shoulders are down they're breathing
like this they get distracted by all the
things around them there's no energy
really on a vital level and then so what
happened there's no stimulus from being
at the office for some people anymore
and so what happens is people's lives
have gone down to a low level of energy
well I believe that you have to build
belief belief is like there's an
after-school special believed where the
mom says believe in yourself and that's
all great but there's also a guilt
belief confidence comes from the thing
that you built you must build belief you
must build confidence until you're able
to really put yourself into that dream
but don't make dreams your master that's
where you truly become what you're
destined to become a lot of people sit
back and they dream about being
a sports figure or dream about being a
seal or dream about being an astronaut
and all it is is a dream they don't put
the work behind the dream that dream has
become the master
when you become the master of dream is
when you say I want to go be a Navy SEAL
you say okay I'm gonna lose 106 pounds
in less than three months the dream was
the one thing I thought about and the
dream was now gone now what comes in the
dream goes away and the laundry list of
details and tasks come up gotta do this
God do this God do this gotta do this
that's when you become the master of
your dream
so a lot of people out there dreaming if
you're going to get a new result if
you're going to grow your business if
you're going to be able to support your
mom if you're going to get rid of the
anxiety if you're going to be able to
overachieve and not have all that fear
inside of you you obviously need to get
a new result you're going to have to get
new action we all know that you don't
get new results with old actions doing
the same thing what human beings can do
is amazing what they will do is usually
disappointing it's not because we're not
capable of it it's because we don't have
new actions because we get in certain
emotional states that dominate us like
anxiety like fear of failure right like
the fear of the loss of your mother as
an example so if you're in a state of
fear you're going to behave very
differently and get very different
result and then if you were in a place
of being courageous or bold or warm or
connected or playful any of those so the
most important key to changing your life
in any situation is to change results
you got to change Behavior but to change
Behavior you're going to change the
emotional state you're in if you take
that same person and you change the
tempo they move you bring their
shoulders back and change their
breathing pattern if they make a faster
gesture if they speak more rapidly it
fires off a different biochemistry in
you and in that state you will take
radically different actions put both
your hands on your hips like Wonder
Woman or Superman or that stuff right if
you stand like this and you breathe deep
for just two minutes
what the science found was that you will
absolutely increase your testosterone by
20 man or woman you'll drop your
cortisol which as you know is the stress
hormone by 22 and you're 33 more likely
to take action with you wouldn't have
before because fear would have stopped
you so if you are in a situation you
think of the worst scenario your mom
dying no my business goes under I never
achieve at the level I need to all the
things I have anxiety about the minute
you focus on them you go into those
states of fear and then you behave
fearful and you get lousy results and we
get lousy results what does it do to
your brain you go see I told you I
couldn't do this it becomes this
negative Loop if you focus on what you
want life has probabilities there's no
guarantees but you increase them when
you change your state and that's really
what this is all about learning to
change your body and learning to change
your focus we have the ability to no
matter what our circumstances are get
better so as a human why wouldn't I
every day try to be the best version of
me you didn't necessarily live to be a
hundred but the time you had on Earth
you put in work and then you went and
dominated one area and then you started
coming over and said now I'm coming to
some other areas that are not my errors
per se but I'm gonna bring my greatness
over here and I'm gonna kill it and
that's all I'm saying to people
greatness is in you activated but what
you're activating is the norm this isn't
right that isn't right I'll do whatever
it takes to make that happen get up
early get a PhD write a book put a bunch
of free videos up online learn a second
rank I'll do whatever it takes to keep
this freedom I'll do whatever it takes
there's enough people that are telling
us we can't do it that we're not good
enough why do we want to tell ourselves
that we know for a fact that thoughts
influence actions why do we want to say
that negative self-talk to ourselves we
need to get our own self-affirmations
Muhammad Ali what was his
self-affirmation
I am the greatest
there need to be quiet moments in your
bedroom that we need to reaffirm I am
the captain of my ship and the master of
my fate
that is my affirmation we're supposed to
be different folks and when people look
at us
believe in yourself